c'est toujours leur de barbarie ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
vous le savez très bien vous jusqu'à
amiens qui n'ont mais draguer isabelle
pour moi il jabel bon choix
dire que vous avez envie de faire
quelque chose avec elle vous parlez aux
giscard ou thiel moreau l'a alors
giscard tout du conte alors est ce que
vous feriez vous est-ce que voudriez
dîner avec moi mais je panique s'était
déjà fait président à vous avait dîné
avec lui non on était en été on n'était
qu'un journaliste considère pas que
c'est dean alors qu'en fait vous à
draguer quand vous savez il m'a pas
draguer on a fait un séjour en boîte on
a fait un trajet un long trajet en
voiture ou alors est dit que j'étais
charmante et tous et pas
il n'y a rien eu il m'a banon ouais non
quand toute cette histoire pour rien
c'est à dire on a perdu à domicile je
suis sûr qu'elle est pudique et qu'elle
veut pas balancer mais qu'elle a
forcément été draguera broschi normale a
été draguée par tous et je peux vous
dire je pense qu'elle a été elle a eu
des aventures on ressort les mêmes jeux
[Musique]